bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang got standee
here thank you so much for taking the
time to do this thanks anthony for
having me here
pleasure for sure let's just jump right
into your background uh you've built one
of the more popular d5 protocols
uh but before you did that you had uh
kind of a whole another career so talk a
little bit about
your background and before you found uh
bitcoin crypto blockchain ethereum etc
yeah totally um i i think i've been in
the space now
roughly in general building things in
blockchain
over four and a half years and uh
pretty much uh kind of like smart
project-based uh applications
credit finance and before that actually
i was i was in the legal industries
and also i started to study law uh
before that so i'm on my
i'm kind of a high education a lawyer uh
and the reason i actually went to law
was because before that i was building
uh financial applications uh with two
applications so practically what
is today banks and so forth and i i
started
practicing uh building products very
early uh i
i actually uh my brother uh
was had a lot of influence on this uh he
loved to
develop things on open source uh manual
linux and
uh somehow i also catch up the the
programming there
uh when it was quite young and uh
yeah some of the applications were quite
interesting actually it was more related
to
uh financing app developers uh who
releases
applications in let's say app store
google play
and constantly with fintech i run into
regulation i was quite young 18 19 back
then and that
kind of got me to starting law i just
wanted to understand like how
you know the rules of business and rules
of regulation work
and that was good position because there
i actually started to
think about contracts like legal
agreements and how to make them
efficient
because they usually aren't many times
if you have a dispute you are not going
to the court because the system sucks
and uh you need to pay for it and
there's a high chance of risk that
you get a bad decision from them and
what what blockchain does
and allows to do is that you can
actually have piece of code
uh so-called smartphone checks that
doesn't change so once you deploy
the code into a public blockchain ledger
it executes exactly how it's uh
programmed and this is for example how
bitcoin works uh if you if you send
transaction from one address to another
and you have the right practically
instructions
it it cannot go to anywhere else and
this is just a
simple example of what what may be uh
inspired to come and build financial
applications and i started with the
video because
uh it was more kind of like an open
system where you can do
quite complex stuff in a more uh
what i was wanted to build back that day
when i started
give us an overview of what you're
working on now with ave
like i mentioned it's become one of the
most popular d5 protocols
uh what is it and how does it work
yeah in essence uh what what obvious it
allows uh
the the users to come come to ave and
and practically deposit cryptographic
asset
and see them to grow and that's how
simple it is so traditionally when
we look at uh cryptocurrencies and
digital assets
we usually hold the uh market exposure
so it's kind of like we believe in the
technology we believe in the culture
and and we believe that there is some
future of the
of of of the asset that we are holding
whether it's bitcoin ethereum or
or ave or some some other asset that is
uh
in the cryptographic uh form and what's
interesting here is that
uh what ave allows us to do is that you
cannot you kind of get a
cash flow for your asset so not only you
have the market exposure but you also
have the cash flow
in form of interest rates and this is
what what other practically does so when
you deposit
uh you you basically start to see your
balance growing and at the same time you
can borrow from the protocol against
your deposit so let's say you could
deposit
a bitcoin which is uh kind of like
ethereum form bitcoin or
ethereum uh in in which you might be in
long position but
at the same time you can borrow
so-called stable points which which are
usd uh banked harnesses that you could
use in in
decentralized finance for example got it
and so when you think through this um
the
idea of decentralization uh versus the
centralized entities
talk me through the framework right
because the actual
product um you know experience or the
product functionality
uh that you're building here it exists
in the centralized world right there's
plenty of companies that do
uh some version of this uh what is the
advantages in your opinion between
uh centralization versus the
decentralization and then why
choose to uh to build this as a kind of
a d5 protocol rather than go build it as
one of those centralized entities
yeah that's a good question because i i
see been a benefit in the bulk system
i like the kind of like a blending
models that there is now for example in
centralized finance where we have block
pi we have celsius
and whatnot and what what there is
interesting is that
uh it definitely allows flexibility uh
for example you can get
if loans uh against crypto collateral
for example
uh fiat currencies but what what what's
beneficial in d5 is that uh practically
because everything
is on on smartphone uh you kind of see
all the transactions there and you can
see also exposure there
so when a user or anyone is looking at
the
other protocol you actually see what's
going on there
and uh that means anyone can audit for
example
uh what are the exposures there in terms
of risk
and and what kind of collaterals they
are used and what is the current
liquidity there
and also many of these things are
actually built in rules
so because they're based on on smart
contracts it actually means that
uh you can't uh change those rules
arbitrary if
if you want to change them you
practically need to deploy new contracts
and invite that liquidity there or
then you have some sort of like a uh
governance model which is stock
and base and the community governs how
those rules could be
changed and uh what's surprising is that
actually
even centralized lenders are using d5
in the back end so they're also
connecting to the liquidity
so liquidity doesn't actually look at
whether it's in centralized minus or
decent plus minus it just finds its way
where
there's arbitrage and centralized
finance has different kinds of grids
than decent plus finance
but some decentralized finance might
have risk related to some amount of
liquidity and also like the technical
risk which is
practically smartphone jacks uh and so
forth but i think like the transparency
and the fact that rules are built into
the uh
contracts is the main key component here
yeah and so when you think through this
um there's a couple of different aspects
to the decentralized finance right
there's obviously
uh what i'll call kind of a base layer
in ethereum
um which is serving as one protocol uh
there's then
kind of other key components of
infrastructure uh that applications will
be built on top of
and then there's the actual applications
themselves that have kind of
um you know built on top of a protocol
and they're kind of the interface if you
will
or the user experience to the user how
do you think of ave
and kind of where it fits in that
technology stack in the decentralized
world
yeah i think kind of like a i thought we
definitely have this this
uh uh we we have this
horizontal approach in in in the sense
that we're building
we build a protocol and and that we are
constantly improving with the community
and that means that that protocol is
accessible
by other smart contracts and other uh
kind of applications that that so some
of the developers might build on top of
it so it's practically developers
protocol
uh mainly because it's it's developer
friendly it's very easy to integrate the
documentation's
uh quite uh good in the sense and
that is kind of like how we went to the
market uh when we launched
the protocol last year uh but we also
kind of
have always had the focus for the past
years whatever we have built that we
actually want to get
touch in the end user so everyone else
was trying to solve
in 2018 2019 and 17
even uh kind of like let's build a
protocol
uh that some other protocol will use and
and kind of
the the end user aspect just disappeared
somewhere and no one was taking
responsibility of creating financial
products for end user and we always
wanted to kind of like
have this connection and that is why we
also built a
uh user interface where you could
connect with with your own wallet so
it's practically bring your own wallets
and
you you come there and it's swept
through a connection then you can
actually deposit into alba
earn or borrow against so so we we
definitely do have the
both of the approaches so so most of the
liquidity comes from other places i mean
there's over 100 different integrations
and products built
on top of ave but we're very proud that
we also kind of
like focus on the user experience and
try to get all the way to the
end user uh as well so it's kind of
weird
doing two things at the same time but
it's uh it makes sense as well
talk a little bit about kind of the
governance uh mechanisms that you have
talk a little bit about kind of
um you know the token uh versus the
protocol
and for those that are unfamiliar with
how some of these decentralized
protocols work just kind of walk
us through it yeah so uh
kind of like now many of the the the d5
protocols are based on on kind of like a
governance
and there used to be before this whole
governance period that is
is very fascinating at the moment there
used to be this idea of that
once you deploy uh decent class finance
the contracts
you should should not change them you
should not upgrade the protocols and
that should be immutable code uh which i
kind of agree because
in the sense uh you know you you want to
have this
certainty and use the blockchain power
uh and kind of like the
immutability and and but at the same
time i understand that kind of like when
you deploy something you might want to
fix some sort of
box or you might want to improve the
protocol because innovation is something
that
uh constantly evolves and uh i think
whenever you deploy code
it means uh that your code because it's
public it has
a uh expiry date and that means that
someone else is looking at your code and
they're developing the next innovation
so
you need to kind of like continue
innovating and what governance allows
you to do is you can actually
deploy code and uh it's not immutable
completely at that point
but what what it means is that you can
uh control
how to upgrade that code based on the
token governance
and the beauty here in the system is
that you practically
uh control arbitrary change those
parameters for example
uh our risk parameters in the protocol
might be how much you can borrow against
bitcoin or ethereum uh what kind of
asset could be listed into the protocol
and and this is kind of like what the
governance decides
and all the token holders uh in in the
in the process
and this is kind of interesting because
uh
it actually they are actually
controlling a
protocol now that has roughly uh over
six billion
uh six billion worth of value locked in
those
contracts which is kind of like
fascinating at the same time
and all the like interest that the
borrowers are paying
uh partially is set aside into the
protocol uh
doubt visually treasury so now is this
organization which actually governs it
and in the future it could be
distributed anyways giving grants or
or back practically back to the token
holders or however
the community decides to end of the day
so when you think through this a
centralized entity would essentially
build a product they would have users
come in
uh they would have that revenue
generation from the users
and then the centralized entity has a
centralized p l and that's where kind of
all of the profits would reside
right when it comes to these
decentralized entities
uh in many cases it's going into a pool
and it's either being distributed on
kind of a pro rata basis of ownership of
the tokens
or there's some sort of voting mechanism
as to what to do with those funds
how exactly does the revenue that is
generated by
ave where does that go and then kind of
how does that get distributed to
stakeholders whether it's
uh you know people who have the
equivalent of equity the governance the
tokens et cetera
yeah this that's a good question so but
each and every asset that is in the
protocol has
its own so-called reserve factor which
practically means like
based on risk assessments of the
community and
also partially of the other team actuary
it's decided uh what what should what
could be the reserve factor
uh which means what is the amount of
interest generated to the depositors
is set aside actually to be of the
treasury and currently it started to
accumulate
uh in the version 2 launch which was uh
during
mid of uh uh december and and actually
those ones are sitting in that
uh treasury now treasury so only the
the other token holders can decide what
to do with that treasury
but the cool part is that uh the
treasury is growing in the form of
a token so uh quickly to explain what
are a tokens is that
uh as a depositor as a normal user when
you deposit into the other protocol
uh let's say uh usdc uh 100 usdc
you get in return 100 a usdc which is
kind of like a certificate of of what
you
deposited kind of received into the
protocol
and and that ausdc grows in your
balance algorithmically all the time
whatever you store it
and that is practically interest bearing
token so if you send it to your
friend it still keeps going and so forth
it's kind of like a
very interesting uh concept and kind of
global permission
savings account so the treasury actually
also grows in eight tokens so
even like they're not uh allocated yet
anywhere they're still
are working there and growing uh in
balance as
same way as the eight token holders are
getting getting
their balance increases and the other
governance practically what we are now
working uh
uh quite a lot is to create a
grant program from the dao that
practically some of the
uh a mechanism where community
developers
just come and and get grounds uh and and
how the process is actually working in
terms of voting
uh you actually don't need to vote
yourself so so let's say
uh you know previously governance
decentralized governance
you expect it kind of like that everyone
will participate and vote
but the truth is that not everyone wants
to actually
be part of participating actively so you
could actually delegate your voting
power to someone else
so-called protocol policies and
separately you could actually
uh delegate your proposition power to
let's say a developer that could create
those
uh proposals and put them into the
blockchain practically
pieces of code and the protocol uh
politicians will vote on those
uh proposals uh better uh whatever is
kind of like
their agenda and your mandate to give
them so
it's it's very fascinating uh part of
the whole
whole kind of like uh uh dfi part
for sure and so let's kind of play
devil's advocate for a second right
there's a bunch of people out there who
uh would argue hey why do you need a
token let's maybe start with that first
right so when you've got the token
element to this
um talk through a little bit as to is
there the
possibility to do it a different way and
if not then how you thought of the
design of the token specifically yeah
definitely you could do it without a
token
and practically you have some cons there
and and one of the things is for example
when we
uh and i will go into as well
tell an example why the token is also
important in the in the kind of like
back stopping the protocol but you
could actually deploy the same very same
code and then put it on chain
but the thing is that uh if you need to
change the code and all the
all the other liquidity that is there
and you deploy another practically
uh pool what you need to do is you need
to then migrate all the liquidity so you
need to say to the user that
we draw everything from this pool and
put it to the on our pool so it creates
a bit of like a
user interface issue and i think kind of
like uh
being able to upgrade pools in the
future
uh but which is kind of like you have a
high threshold on
what can be upgraded and what can be
changed is very important in the sake of
innovation because
if you stop innovating and they find
someone else comes and continues
that innovation which practically means
that that other community has
has more innovation uh kind of like an
influence
and might get better network effects but
in terms of like the
governance token that we have uh in
essence the avatar holders they are
practically making uh risk-based
decisions all the time
and that means that if you uh they're
voting for listing new assets that could
be used as a platform
are voting for risk parameters for
example how much you can borrow against
a certain particular asset
so they they they're adding constantly
risk or removing
risk and and once they're doing that
actually there's a ability in them to
transfer the risk themselves so we have
this kind of like a
safety module where the other token
holders can deposit
uh their over tokens there and get
rewards in ave
and what they're actually doing is
they're backstopping the protocol
so let's say uh if there's some sort of
like a exploit hack that leads to a
deficit in the protocol
uh in that case up to 30 of that stake
can be slashed
and covered uh the protocol and this is
uh
kind of like something that was very
important to add because we were
thinking during
beginning of 2020 that what's the most
important thing to us
and and to get the protocol to scale and
that's practically the
posits and how to get the liquidity is
that we have to provide as safe as
possible
or a call for the depositors and and and
also
beyond that like we have to have a way
that if there's some sort of uh
uh mistake happening and could be an
exploit or something because
people code and also like uh it's not
always
we've we've seen identify quite a lot of
hacks and we have to achieve comfort
level if you go to the mainstream and
also institutional ad option
so so what the protocol governance is
actually doing not just
risk-based decision but they're
backstopping the protocol as well
from this kind of like a uh risks
and so when you think through um kind of
how this has grown so far
what are some of the high level
statistics right just in terms of market
adoption because one of the things that
um i think is really important
conversation is uh there's a lot of
tribalism there's a lot of kind
of kind of religiousness in uh in crypto
uh whether that's good or bad i'll leave
that debate to other people
but the one thing that uh is very clear
is that in many cases we can just see
what the market is adopting and so
uh when it whether it's on-chain data
whether it's companies revealing
you know kind of their metrics and their
growth when you think of ave
kind of what are the high level metrics
that you're proud of and then also that
you think is important for people to
understand just in terms of uh kind of
validating the market adoption
yeah what's what's important of course
kind of like is
is that the the the the market size
itself in
in obvious so we have probably just uh
six billion worth of value locked in the
contract which means that's the
collaterals used for the borrowings
and and of course like uh we have this
so-called flashlight
functionality which means that uh you
could borrow
a from the protocol without a collateral
for one
uh one block one ethereum block and it
works in a way that
you can do in one block many kind of
transactions but then you need to sit on
that block which practically means that
you can borrow
from from other with a platter buy an
asset in in
exchange one and selling that said in
extent decentralized extensions too
and then return the kind of like a
flashlight and if you don't return all
of those transactions will fail because
you failed to
fulfill one of the conditions of that
first transaction so that's
in essence the rational there's a lot of
information
out there in the uh in the so-called the
internet about
uh classrooms and way more technical
explanations uh
i will leave it to you guys but that's
kind of like uh we had two billion worth
of flash loans
uh last year so that's an important
metric but even more important metric is
that we have
so far in this year 2 billion worth of
flashlights
so that kind of shows like how in in
intensity growth is but uh i also like
to emphasize the interest rates because
that also tells like
uh what kind of liquidity crisis there
and not just prices not
prices but punch uh there is an other
because apparently the yields are at
eight nine percent past 30 days which
practically means that
there's nothing of liquidity in or in
dfi in general and
this is the moment where actually now
institutions are looking
at those fields and looking how they can
participate
and kind of like quantifying assessing
and it's not hard
i mean it is hard for institutional to
participate because
it's it's just defy is a bit bespoke
and and everything is completely new and
i think like
uh for example the uh tesla
practically taking bitcoin their balance
sheet and those kind of moves
like they just strengthened the
narrative of like
uh what blockchain what cryptocurrency
is
what this point is and eventually kind
of like it expands
the idea that actually you know you find
opportunities not only in traditional
finance
but in this completely damaged new world
but
for us it's kind of like we've been like
kind of like uh
been been here for a while and trying to
uh uh
kind of spread the uh message
absolutely uh when you think about uh
what you're building it is
you know decentralized finance it's on
the cutting edge uh
if it is successful uh it will disrupt a
lot of what goes on in the traditional
world
how do you think about interfacing with
that legacy world
with any of the legacy banking
institutions is it something where you
just say nope we're not even gonna you
know
really uh worry about them and we're
just gonna go build our thing and if it
disrupts it it disrupts them
uh but they kind of have to catch us as
the innovators or do you see ways that
uh you can work with them and interface
with them that's in a kind of a win-win
or a mutually beneficial manner
yeah i think in ideal world uh
practically you know traditional
appointments
in in decentralized finance they they
pretty much need to work together
in the sense uh i i think there's been
kind of like many years that we have
been
doing bespoke things we have a different
kind of terminology
uh we have different kind of culture we
have a very strong mean culture that's
the kind of like
that's that's that's what that's the the
product of the freedom if you can
innovate and have fun at the same time
and with traditional finance i think uh
you know
why defy is growing so fast and also
like building
uh protocols in general underlying
protocols as well if you take a look at
like
what's what's the uh
what kind of development there is
actually in in bitcoin in
the ethereum protocol and and indeed in
general
i don't know about other protocols i
don't follow follow them but you know
this is really what i i actually i keep
my eye on
and the reason that it's it's moving so
fast is pretty much because
the the the technology is open source
and anyone can contribute
and that practically means that uh you
know it's
there's no competitive modes we all are
there you define a war zone
in a good way you know we look at what
others are doing we try to improve our
protocol
and if you look at uh like the only
thing that matters is this constant
innovation
and and and how your team is able to do
and innovate constantly this is the kind
of thing i'm looking
in our team and also like in other teams
i'm trying to help in this space
and if you look at traditional finance
there's a lot of molds and this small
thinking is it's exactly what for
example warren buffett and
the previous financial uh
kind of like uh advocates are are
telling that you need to find your mode
but in b5 there is no modes it's just
like
you need to constantly innovate and the
only way kind of like
you you could uh survive is you need to
contribute as well
and this is what happens has happened in
linux form because
it's not anymore in linux that there's
uh two and a half thousand
uh contributors uh contributing for
every release but
a big part of those contributors are
actually people working in in bigger
companies and contributing to linux
uh because it's mission critical
software and i believe in future also
traditional finance and banks are also
contributing into these open source
protocols
and that's good for them as well because
it it kind of shifts
the legacy systems that they have into
this kind of like a better
back end of finance and they can focus
on creating better
services for the uh their own user base
and so when you think through um kind of
the regulatory framework right so we
talked a little bit about interfacing
with the banks and the cooperation there
uh you guys have this kind of license uh
in the british
financial system maybe talk a little bit
about the license that you have
uh why that's important as you continue
building this and then kind of
how you think about even though it's
decentralized
you know kind of by nomenclature you
still have licenses and so does that
mean that all of d5 will eventually kind
of have regulations around it or just
how you think through that
yeah so practically what we have uh so
there's two things there's the
there's the decentralized protocol that
is running autonomously on the
uh on the ethereum blockchain and it's
covered by the
community token holder community but
also we basically have an entity that is
responsible for integrations and
building businesses
on top of the protocol so there's like
two separate
kind of like a thing and uh with this
entity that we have in uk we basically
uh went and applied for electronic money
license and the idea is there that we
we want to build gateways into the
decent class finance
and that means that means for the
mainstreamers
that actually don't have direct access
to d5 they could actually
uh convert their pounds dollars uh
euros into stable points and then
interest bearing stable points and
get the d5 exposure but in terms of like
regulation these are two different
things
and and kind of like it boils down to
this bigger discussion like
like how to regulate protocols because
if you think about it uh so
so bitcoin is a protocol ethereum is a
protocol and
d5 the decentralized d5 protocols they
are
they're all financial protocols in one
way or another and they have some
inflation which is a kind of way to
reward
uh the upholders of the network and and
then
many d5 protocols they they have just
wider functionality than
than let's say securing a network uh
what
what our system does our contracts it
basically secures
blending and borrowing laterals and so
forth so in in this sense like
if you think about all of these decent
plus protocols it's kind of like an
ocean
and i think like when it comes to
regulation uh what's the best thing and
most efficient
regulator is actually the ports that
provides the access to the ocean and
that's the kind of like
exchanges of the world and and the front
front ends that
take custody of the user funds and i
actually believe uh
this might be actually happening is that
uh the bigger
the the biggest ports will be those
centralized uh
uh participants that are having now
let's say centralized
exchanges or centralized lending
services
and i think those will be the kind of
like a gateways to dfi
so when you think about the biggest
obstacles right
is uh for the developing of uh this
ecosystem
and specifically ave and the
decentralized protocol
uh that you're building what are the
biggest obstacles or challenges moving
forward
yeah i i think kind of one of the
biggest issues in my opinion is
definitely that
we are trying to build like we are
trying to use the same security
into you know all the transactions that
we have for example if you take a look
at
uh the bitcoin network so what's
interesting about bitcoin is that you
know
you have this network that uses the most
uh sound and kind of like a security
method
to ensure the store of value right so
practically
uh it's very difficult to break that
protocol
uh because of the the consensus
mechanism and you're using electricity
to
to kind of like secure the network and
and that's that's very good
in terms of like like storing of value
and when we look at for example what's
going on in ethereum what's interesting
there is that
you know all the transactions are not
equal so let's say
uh you might have a trading
functionality or you might have
uh lending a borrowing
you might have actually gaining their uh
collectibles
so it's just like opera operating system
where you can have any kind of an
application
it depends how you code it and what's
the
challenge there is that it's kind of
like a traffic jam at the moment because
everyone wants to build and use the same
level of security
which practically means uh that you know
the network gets
congested and everyone is paying the
same
price which is actually the high price
so now the kind of like a question is
that
how we solve the scalability so how we
can
apply the security uh where you needed
more
and and apply less security where you
actually don't need it that much
this is like where the discussions of
layer choose come in
so for example if you have side change
on ethereum that you actually can
actually do most of the transactions and
settle
into into the ethereum network and
and keep the state that way so i think
that's the kind of like apparent
uh challenge that we have in the
whole ecosystem got it and then when you
think about
um kind of the user experience or the
user interface
uh obviously uh when you compare it to i
don't know
let's say square or robin hood right
maybe the functionality is different but
just the
kind of slick uh design the gamification
uh there's so many things that they've
done really well that make it dead
simple for
users to use those uh kind of fintech
platforms
uh d5 um bitcoin ethereum
and kind of all of the products they
don't have a lot of that same
uh kind of design superiority if you
will
is that going to change how will it
change what is needed to kind of
drive that change just kind of talk a
little bit about you know what's going
to happen from a user experience in your
user interface standpoint yeah
definitely i agree and like a few years
ago
i mean the user experience was more
horrible so it was so difficult you
don't have even stable coins and
and it's very like uh everything was way
more clunkier back then so
we we have we have improved quite a lot
but even now like
in terms of like user experience uh it's
it's it's not that super
actually bad because you know depositing
into ave is just one
one transaction away if you have uh
already
uh assets in in your uh wallet i think
like
and same if you want to swap tokens
there's very easy way to do it in for
example in balancer and so forth
but uh the kind of challenge is like how
do you enter into space when you are not
like crypto native
so for crypto native people like like
you and me it's just like
it's that simple right but then when i
go to someone else to a friend
that isn't in the ecosystem like how
they will understand and how they
understand to store their keys and
i think it's it's it's a question also a
bit about education so i really like the
did we recently on on what elo mosque
actually tweeted that you know you
should kind of like
uh avoid avoid wallets where you don't
have the keys
because that's the kind of like a thing
and i don't think that actually
you you need to avoid i mean you need to
choose but that's like the main thing
that people need to be
educated in and uh i think like
uh in terms of like the approach why
robin hood and
how they improve the the the kind of
like user experience is
because they those applications were
invented to
to basically fix the user experience the
same way as financial technology fintech
is invented to
improve the normal banking experience
and and what dfi was invented and let's
say uh
it was invented actually to fix fix the
back end completely so the approach is
completely different like we came here
to fix like what actually is very legacy
system
and make that better and now we're
working our way
like down all the way to the user
experience which is kind of like now the
last part that is going to get fixed
and in fintech dropping hoots they
actually started from the user
experience
so they they kind of they they have an
interesting approach there and that's
why like
you know they get traction but we're
working towards
uh fixing that it's the last step but
it's the most important one
i love that uh if you zoom out you look
20 25 years from now
talk to me about the future of d5 is it
the dominant
financial system is everything
decentralized it's all open protocols
uh and users are using it uh you know
kind of the centralized
uh system is completely forgotten and uh
they've had a transition to the d5 world
is it a coexistence what does that world
look like and kind of how do you just
think about the future of d5 you know 20
25 years out
i i think uh what will happen is is that
d5 will be quite big
so so uh definitely like it will be a
kind of like an ocean like put it the
ocean and you could plug in
uh you could draw liquidity from from
this ocean and and you can supply
liquidity
but i don't think like a i don't think
it replaces completely like uh
centralized providers or centralized
finance because in in essence like uh
it definitely brings efficiencies but uh
kind of like you don't want to put
everything on chain
because it's costly and in some cases
you want to use a database
uh and you know instead of just
periodically
in the main chain and most of the
financial transactions might happen
in a trust network so let's say if you
have circle you have revolut
you know they could interact between
each other by using uh
the the the blockchain but also if they
have a trust network
and and they have funds in let's say
bitcoin and
theory they could also decide between
each other that hey we trust each other
so let's just move database numbers
and save some transaction codes and we
both have like a good relationship so
it doesn't need to bolt down all the way
to practically
that let's have all the databases in uh
blockchain because you know
you would have to apply that security
cost and i i'm not sure if
all the like oh billions of people want
to
you know pay for that and uh but
it will empower a lot of people so now
if you take a look at the a tokens for
example
uh it actually is a permissions global
savings account so
anyone who holds that that those tokens
are actually getting
uh usd nominated uh yield so so they
actually have a
access to stable currency usd nominated
and
and that increases in balance and that's
what
cool thing especially in places where
you have local currency that sucks
completely
and like has this kind of like huge
inflation
and and uh i i think it's it will
empower quite a lot of people
and i think we're thinking we're doing
it very well in the deposit side
and now where we kind of like are trying
to work is in the borrowings out how we
can make underplated
loans and how we can make this system
work and empower people
and i think d5 is just one thing i mean
there's more in life than finance right
so it's pretty cool that if you can
empower
things that are non-dfi related nfd
space greater economy you know like
traders that are
creating art and accessing to the space
or through labor
and helping they're out and off chain as
well so i i think like there's way more
cooler things than
finance and i hope that we can empower
to some extent
absolutely what what do you think is uh
the other
interesting projects in the space and
you've done a ton of angel investing and
you probably can't name all of them that
you think are interesting but just two
or three that off the top of your head
you find
fascinating uh valuable and worth paying
attention to
i i like the uh project uh it's called
power swap
so so practically what they're doing is
they're uh i mean default liquidity is
all over the place so you have this this
like decentralized exchanges
that work in audible fashion which are
very complicated to use and then you
have this kind of like a
automated market makers such as for
example balancer uh
uh uni swap so so there you just provide
the quality and then
other other users could just swap their
uh
assets and then what what uh pyroswop is
doing is that they're pulling all this
liquidity
uh into one place so you just don't need
to shop for
or for your liquidity and just make sure
exchange assets without getting this uh
slippage so this is like a very powerful
thing because it actually like
uh uh pulls all the liquidity into into
one source and
you can integrate that into whatever
you're building uh if you want to access
dfi
like what is the and i i think they're
the interesting part is that they
they do it in a very gas efficient way
so that's
that's something that they're very proud
of uh
and another project which is uh quite
what's fascinating is
is uh called opioid network so it's it's
very
the name is a bit uh funky but what they
actually do is they do derivatives
on chain and what's interesting there
uh is is that they have a system where
they can list different kinds of pickers
and actually provide insurance
in form of uh because insurance is
derivatives and that is what the d5
space
needs at the moment so when we have
institutions they are looking at
what uh you know if they're if they're
depositing into ave
they're kind of like trying to quantify
what's their risk how they how they can
hedge their risk and and and that is why
like each experience plays
uh quite quite a big role uh in space so
those two things are
for me something that has been uh
been progressing recently quite fairly
well
absolutely uh before we finish up i ask
everyone the same three questions
uh the first is um what is the most
important
book that you've ever read
most important uh i i think like
recently i would say the the book's name
was
empire of cotton and and you know
interesting there was because
it was like caught in as a kind of like
community
uh you know we all were pardoned so
uh practice was like how it affected
kind of like our lives over the
centuries and like how it has been like
part of everything that's almost
everything that's happening in this
space and it's
it's it doesn't just tell about cotton
but it also tells about
like instrument in general so let's say
cotton is just a community
uh in one way we see like
cryptocurrencies
as a community or whatever we're
creating and how it plays
like a lot of importance in our culture
and i i think like uh
that was one of the important books and
i don't read much like that's i have to
say
uh it out loud because like i would love
to read but it's just like
being in this space is just like
horrible like if
if anyone is going to deify like like
don't like
think twice like you will like have no
personal life so
you know this is something you need to
think of very seriously
i love it uh the second one's more
personal uh
sleep um i uh i've got friends over at
eight sleep and they've convinced me to
uh to not sleep five or six hours but
more like eight or nine
uh and they felt an awesome product
suite uh including this uh
thermoregulated bed which basically
allows you to make it hot or cold i
sleep super cold
um and i absolutely love the product and
have gotten much much better sleep
because of it what's your sleep schedule
um and kind of how's that evolved over
the years
yeah so uh i have to say the sleep is
the most important thing for me so if i
if i can't get enough sleep i like my
my performance gets it's going to be
very very
weak so it's really like uh if i don't
get like enough dream
or enough like rest like i i definitely
will
will be like a uh weak person and
it's it's just something like it's very
frustrating for me because
you know it's sometimes i need to wake
up middle of the night and help someone
and and uh or just like i have long days
and
you know early wake ups and it's just
killing me because i know that
i'm kind of like angry to myself because
i can't function
properly and and and this is something
it's very difficult so i think sleep is
the most important thing you
you need to have and if you sleep well
you can actually have more healthy
diet as well because you know you don't
your body is working
uh better biologically so i think that's
that's
that's something i also if someone is
looking to
come into dfi you might
say that it's not easy easy to
get some sleep sleep is uh it
is uh completely converted to me i i
like to joke that i'm a convert to the
sleep religion so i'm all in on it
uh last question's more fun aliens are
you a believer or a non-believer
well i i do believe that there might be
some other people
uh looking maybe like us are not like us
so
definitely there might be somewhere i
haven't seen any so that's the problem
like
i i would like to see at some point if
there is but
the probably issue is that traveling
from other place might take some
some of the time but not to sound too
too crazy like
crazy person i mean there's there is
like a lot of
value in the protocol at the moment so i
would say that i believe but i haven't
seen any any
anyone anyone that looks suspicious
absolutely not suspicious uh what what
uh one question do you have for me to
finish up you could ask me one what do
you got for me
yeah maybe i would uh ask you kind of
like uh
a question about uh what do you think
about defy
yeah um look i i think that it's very
obvious that decentralized finance
is going to be you know a thing right
and it's probably going to be the main
thing
um i think that uh there's lots of
people who want to put me
into different buckets right you know
for years people feel like oh he's a
bitcoin maximalist
uh and i've always kind of said no i
actually don't think that i am
um it's just more so that uh most of the
things that i saw in the very very
beginning
of d5 frankly just seemed unsustainable
to me
right and so one of the the examples i
always use is
if you go back to 2010 to like 2015
there was a ton of companies in venture
that would go when they'd brag about
look at how fast we're growing look at
how great our growth rate is
and then what you would realize is like
they weren't actually growing fast
on an organic standpoint they were
simply just spending a bunch of money to
drive
users right so if you look at like the
direct to consumer companies all that
kind of stuff
so when they shut off the advertising
growth shut off
um and so what i think that uh you know
let's look at like yield farming for
example one of the big
kind of knocks i've had there is saying
look it's unsustainable to simply say
hey if you come use
our product we're going to give you you
know 200 300 annualized returns
because we're essentially just using
paid marketing it's a new version of
paid marketing once i
stopped doing paid marketing then like
that kind of mercenary type user
is just going to go find who's paying
300 today right there's going to go run
to the next one and kind of just leave
the protocol to do it
again that doesn't mean that it's um uh
d5 is not going to work it just means
that like that specific application
uh another thing that i've been very
kind of uh critical of
is icos right and so uh in 2017 and into
18 i kept telling people like look
people are going to get in trouble for
this stuff it is
uh the sale of unregistered securities
in the united states i don't think that
that's the best thing that people should
be doing
uh therefore like be careful um and
again i think people took that as like
oh he's anti
you know innovation whatever look i'm
just calling how i see it and
ended up being right on that and so with
all that said of like i've been
very very critical of some parts of it
uh
ultimately i look at decentralized
finance as
uh if you take everything in the
traditional world everything's gonna get
digitized you're gonna have digital
stocks bonds currencies and commodities
that's been my thesis for years
where that plays out i think is where a
lot of the debates like when people say
like what do you think about d5 like
everyone wants to go debate like what
technology stack it gets built on
to me it's like before we even get into
that debate it's just like of course
decentralized finance is going to be a
thing like you got to be an idiot to not
think that at this point what that
entails though i probably have a nuanced
view right like
digi uh digital decentralized money
right a kind of an open protocol like
bitcoin
to me is d5 right so like that is dec
part of decentralized finance it's not
the totality of d5 but it's also not
excluded from d5 right it's one piece of
it you've got to have decentralized kind
of sound money
then if you start to go and you look at
let's take what you're building or maybe
with uniswap or something like that
like i always just say to people i don't
think i'm smarter than the market
right and like you can't argue against
six billion dollars locked
in value you can't argue against you
know take a unit swap where they're
doing between 600
million to maybe a billion dollars in
annualized fees on that exchange like
those are big numbers that are very very
compelling and so
i think that everyone gets caught up in
this like religious war to some degree
and to me it's just like look i actually
don't care if it gets built on bitcoin
if it gets built on ethereum or gets
built on some protocol that hasn't been
started yet right like at the end of the
day i just know that we're going to have
a decentralized open digital financial
system
and really just a digital open
decentralized
system in general not just finance but
kind of everywhere
and so for me like i'm not a developer
like i'm not going to be the one to go
build the
uh kind of overarching dominant platform
instead i just want to understand like
who's building what and where is the
market adopting things and then just go
and accelerate what's already happening
right as an investor and kind of someone
with a large audience
that's my greatest contribution is i can
provide capital and then i can provide
distribution
uh from kind of an awareness and user
acquisition standpoint
and so i've been spending a lot of time
kind of just trying to understand you
know what's working what's not working
uh kind of what do people think is
sustainable what do people not think is
sustainable
uh but to you know it's just a foregone
conclusion if you fast forward you know
20 25 years that like
everything is going to be decentralized
everything's going to be digital
and everything's going to be on these
open protocols uh i think that just
people
get caught up in like the debate today
of you know which one wins on this
fact or that fact and at the end of the
day like a lot of them are doing
different things right like it's
you wouldn't say that abe is competing
with unit swap you wouldn't say that ave
and uniswap are competing with bitcoin
right like those are all different
things going after different use cases
different problems
and so i think that people just have to
remember that like the world's not as
black and white as they want it to be
uh and the nuance is important here so
that's kind of my general thoughts on it
yeah i i definitely agree i mean those
were pretty good points i mean
like you have different kinds of
protocols and and different kinds of
applications and
and i think uh the deep voice kind of
like
wider than we see and that's something
that
people need to go over with this kind of
like tribalism because like there's like
there's so many things to build you know
so many people to help it's just that
this makes sense to stop kind of like
and you know
push back because there's just uh
there's just innovation and
opportunities everywhere
like and you can build them very well
and that's that's the cool part
absolutely i completely agree where can
we send people to find you on the
internet or find out more about ave
i i think uh on the uh
twitter uh of the obvious or handle so
so following that is there's sort of
stuff our discord you'll find our
discord there as well over.com
uh you will find greats and and also
others
uh social media diagram i'm pretty
active myself it's it's
but people get quite amazed that they
can actually reach me out
and i like to keep it that way uh you
know can't
it can't you know be disgusting whole
day on topics but you know
but but still i i love to talk to people
so
that's pretty cool i love it you do a
fantastic job
uh people obviously find it valuable so
keep going
and uh do this again in the future
yeah definitely thanks for having me
here anthony